data science and data analytics are they
the same thing well you may have seen
these terms used interchangeably but if
I'm mining data from a large data set am
I performing data science or am I
performing data analytics or what if I'm
trying to create a prediction of when my
store will sell out of our current
inventory of cantelopes well is that
analytics or is that science it's
worthwhile to understand the difference
to better comprehend what these two
Fields can do and also if you're
considering a career in either field
after all these are two different jobs
somebody who works in the field of data
science is known as a data
scientist for data analytics that role
is called a data
analyst now this is kind of a trick
question because we can classify
everything data mining data forecasting
and all the rest of it as simply data
science and that's because data science
is the overarching umbrella term that
covers tasks related to finding patterns
in large data sets training machine
learning models and deploying AI
applications data analytics it could be
argued is one task that resides under
the data science umbrella it's
specialization of data science and it
focuses on querying interpreting and
visualizing data
sets data science is iterative meaning
data scientists form hypotheses and
experiments to see if a desired outcome
can be achieved using available data and
that is a process that is known as the
data science life cycle which usually
follows seven phases so first is to
identify a problem or an
opportunity then the next phase is data
mining which is to extract data relevant
to that problem or opportunity from
large data sets now that data will
likely consist of a bunch of
redundancies and errors which is fixed
in the next stage data cleaning and then
at that point we move on to data
exploration analysis to try to make
sense of that data we'll then apply
feature engineering using domain
knowledge to extract details from the
data and predictive modeling comes next
to use the data to predict or forecast
future outcomes and behaviors and then
finally we have data
visualization that represents the data
points with graphical tools such as
charts and animations and so the life
cycle repeats now the role of a data
scientist is an in demand profession
right now if that's something you're
interested in you'll want to develop
deep skills in machine learning and AI
it's helpful to be able to write code in
languages such as python also in R is
another popular language for data
science and you should have experience
working with big data platforms so
perhaps
Hadoop or Apache spark and it's also
very helpful to have database knowledge
and SQL so that's that's data science
but what about its specialization data
analytics well the job of a data analyst
is to conceptualize a data set as it
currently exists so we have some data
here and we need to do something with
it and we need to be able to make
decisions based on this data how do we
conceptualize it well four ways one is
through Predictive Analytics which helps
to identify trends correlations and
causation within beta sets like
forecasting when those cantelopes would
have all flown off the shelves or in
healthcare to forecast regions which
will experience a rise in flu cases
there's prescriptive analytics and that
predicts likely outcomes and makes
decision recommendations like predicting
when a tire will wear out and need to be
replaced there's
diagnostic analytics that helps pinpoint
The reason an event occurred
manufacturers can analyze a failed
component on an assembly line and figure
out the reason behind its failure and
then there is descriptive analytics
which evaluates the qualities and
quantities of a data set a Content
streaming provider might use descriptive
analytics to understand how many
subscribers it's lost or how many it's
gained over a given period of time and
what content is being watched and while
a data scientist is a clearly defined
and specialized role virtually any
stakeholder can be a data analyst for
example business analysts can use bi
dashboards to conduct business analytics
and visualize kpis but many
organizations do employ professional
dedicated data analysts responsible for
data wrangling and interpreting findings
like why a company's marketing campaign
didn't meet expectations if you want to
be a data analyst it helps to have both
analytical and programming skills so
this includes familiarity with
databases also you'll need to know about
statistical analysis and also data
visualization is another important skill
so data analytics is often more focused
on using statistical tools and
techniques to interpret existing data
and offer actionable insights it's
usually less concerned with creating new
algorithms or models data science on the
other hand has a broad scope that can
involve complex machine learning
algorithms often created from scratch
data science focuses on phases from data
collection to predictive modeling data
analysis on the other hand is more about
answering specific questions with that
data and if you've done both your data
science and data analytics right you'll
always be able to keep cantelopes and
just about everything else in
stock